is it more of a challenge to raise kids
today more than ever right with social
media with everything you're talking
about about like sort of like the big
brother approach ask why that's what I
want to know why why do you think tell
me I want you to think and you don't
have kids I want you to think why do you
think it's harder today than it was when
we were 12 years old six years old I
mean the the the the first answer that
would have to be social media just
because it has a greater influence than
anything we've ever seen with our I mean
growing up I mean I was the kid that we
would always just play sports in the
front yard that's all it was yeah right
this was pre-beeper pre-cell phone
pre-social media there was no influence
over your life other than at school so
right so can I can I uh uh that's one so
here's give me the easiest product to
sell what's an easy price let's say we
all become sales people okay and Tyler's
our sales leader he wants to teach us
how to sell this product what's an easy
product to sell car okay cool what kind
of a car just a
what's an easy thing where the average
person can learn how to sell
can we say phone ice cream I just have
an iPhone okay no honestly let's just
certain ideas let's just say hi I value
Fitness if you're trying to sell an
iPhone how do you sell an iPhone versus
a Droid
we have to talk about its features its
benefits
green bubbles versus blue FaceTime when
you're flying you can text everybody
it's easier to use easier to use it's
tied to the music all this stuff
certainly so out of 100 people if we try
to train them in one hour can we train
out of 100 people uh on people to learn
how to sell an iPhone hour later okay so
what else is easy to sell gym
memberships yeah a pen what else is easy
to sell clothes yeah what's easy to sell
okay so what's hard to sell what is a
hard product to teach someone to sell
that takes months and months insurance
and months to sell insurance what else
acceptance Financial products but give
me give me specific I want specific what
do you think is hard to teach somebody
to sell I think it's very hard to teach
them to sell like you know life
insurance and annuities they're
technical the benefits what about
fashion like nothing like that no no
technical technology you'll look great
and you can get laid I want that I want
that time that's the product but here's
here's the point I'm trying to make you
when I'm saying like what's hard to sell
what's easy to sell in the 80s every
product you ever sell comes up with a
set of FAQs some it's five frequently
asked questions so tell me what is the
chances that if I buy this real estate
property the Market's going to go down
well how do I protect myself against it
well John Mary are you buying this house
because you're planning on leaving
living here for two years are you
planning to buy live this place for 10
years no we're at least going to live in
this place for 10 years well
historically in the last 10 years if you
look at what's happened to real estate
never has real estate gone down lower
intent so you give that kind of a
rebuttal you got five frequently asked
questions some technical products 20.
some extremely technical products 5200
parents in the 80s had 20 FAQs where do
babies come from okay mommy how much
love was there in this house that we had
a baby my teacher told me babies come
because if there's a lot of love in the
house and then babies are born so if we
only have one baby and they have five
does that mean our household doesn't
have enough love like the other
household has no son that's not really
where babies come from but tell me so
tell me what happens when we die are you
gonna die one day like these questions
that kids ask we ask our parents can you
imagine today one of the FAQs you got to
give to a parent is what's a transgender
and am I one am I being my gay am I
lesbian hey Mommy let me ask you a
question why did you not take the
vaccine why are we taking a vaccine my
teacher told me it's irresponsible to
not take the vaccine are we taking a
vaccine the FAQ of parenting today is
the size of a Bible and parents just
can't keep up anymore that's the biggest
in my opinion that's the biggest
difference of parenting in the 80s
versus today it's like in the 80s you
needed an associate degree to be a
parent today you need a PhD to be a
parent wow you need to go train to learn
how to answer some of these complex
questions with kids it's a challenge
attempt to have kids I think we've also
lost Community when I was growing up I
knew the names of all my neighbors
that's right today you don't know the
names your name if your neighbor says
hello to you they're being nosy and
you're like worried I can remember I was
seven years old I go walking down the
street toward the end of the
neighborhood and the neighbors Drives By
he rolls down his window and he called
me this is Tommy he said yeah where are
you going because he knows I live way
down there I live like five houses down
and what's a seven-year-old walking here
I'm running away from home why are you
doing that because I'm mad he stops his
car opens the door stands up you go home
right now and I'm calling your mom to
tell you tell her that you were down
here walking toward the Main Street
and so I got home because he's calling
my parole officer telling her you
remember this I remember this I was
seven years old and so guess what that
doesn't happen today you don't talk to
my kid you don't yell at my kid but that
Father which was part of the community
of the neighborhood and we weren't all
Republicans we weren't all Democrats
there was different views there but
there is a community that's been lost in
America you don't know your neighbors
and you don't trust your neighbors there
was a time when he thought that I should
tell this kid and all what is the only
thing he did get home I'm calling your
mom that was it by the time I got home
says where were you I was walking down
toward the main road and why were we
doing that and now guess what I got this
that's it this moment with my mom I'm in
my room and I'm waiting for my dad to
get home because I'm not supposed to be
doing this and we all just learned that
and as doc used to be called Tommy Tommy
because I was little and it's the
nickname for a little kid that's such an
important thing you're talking about
Community though and that that's been
lost and there are so many parents Tom
that are now trying to recapture that
because it's exhausting to all those
questions that Pat spouted off for
that's true you have to think what your
kid could come home and ask there's a
lot of people though now that want that
a little bit of that Simplicity back and
they're moving Off the Grid they're
going into the small towns you see a lot
of people leaving the New York cities
they're leaving the miamis they're
leaving the you know even the Austin
Texas's and they're heading out into
into get some land and get and get that
sense of community where there they can
raise their child in a place that's not
woke that's not crazy where the the
school actually teaches them you know
Reading Writing and math and not you
know propaganda all day long and they
don't have to worry about indoctrination
and that they know their neighbors and
there is a sense of community because
think about it too you know the
privileged can hire help can do this but
people need Community often hard-working
people go to work every day and they
like the idea that their kid is part of
a town where that becomes the family
they you all kind of raised each other
back in the day I remember member you
know my neighbors were like aunts and
uncles and that was a beautiful thing
when you strip that away it leaves
people feeling very isolated it leaves
people in lower income brackets
struggling and then what do they do they
have to put their kids into the system
and that then creates the whole Paradigm
we were talking about before where the
kids get indoctrinated so that whole
sense of community is vital and
important I think more and more people
around the country are realizing it and
trying to get it back you know where it
shows up a lot I agree it shows up a lot
it shows up a lot in homeschooling
because homeschooling creates networks
of families together that agree on one
thing
the school is whack and we're going to
homeschool I love it
when they right that's true and but no
but but look what builds up
relationships build up you know because
somebody teaches science because they
knew that or they hire a tutor to be
part of that and homeschooling families
there's you know huge Community that's
growing out of that out of not going up
to the mountains and all being weird
people right this isn't deliverance and
homeschool this is just a community of
people pulling together and saying hey
we're going to homeschool so are we and
they meet all these other families and
there's resources for them there's ACT
Testing and you know what guess what
they also discover they also discover
this community as common citizens so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]